all right autumn yes autumn where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
las cruces new mexico
and uh tell me about how your
childhood was you grew up with both
parents uh no i grew up with my mom and
my stepdad
my mom and
my biological father were never married
my biological father is an alcoholic and
my mom used to be an alcoholic before
she had me
um
she made my setup when i was two
um so i diagnosed breast cancer when i
was five
almost i'm sorry she got diagnosed my my
mother got diagnosed with breast cancer
when i was five stage two breast cancer
and then um
i
hated school well i loved school and i
hated school um
then when i turned 11 my mom got put
into remission for breast cancer
and she divorced my stepdad she found
her
boyfriend when she was 19
and
she moved us in with him
um
i started hanging out at the mall i was
every day all day
um so i started doing like smoking weed
and stuff and cigarettes around the same
time
as happened um
my mom
and her boyfriend would always fight
because she who he also was an uncle
like her new boyfriend
um whose name was john um was a fully
functioning alcoholic
he was a screwdriver while screwdrivers
i wanted using vodka every day all day
he would go to work his adjournment
journeyman's electrician
was so um
you know they would always fight and
like got called like every single day
um so i left my mom's house and i went
to go live with my aunt
uh my aunt who was mentally mentally and
physically disabled she had water in the
brain when she was a baby
and so
we were walking on the street one day
to go to uh to go to a cafe and i saw
this guy outside and i stopped to talk
to him and stuff and
he asked for one hang on i said yeah
so i'm on the way back to my aunt's
house from the cafe um we played with
this guy well this guy was went back
myself walking with us
and we were in the bathroom and he asked
me if i wanted to try some ice and i
said yeah
um
at the time i wasn't aware that ice was
methamphetamine
but anyways i tried anyway um so at age
11 i started doing meth
and um
so i ran in the streets about a year
later
um i officially moved out from my mom's
well she kicked me out sorry she keep me
out
and um
a year later
started
doing math heavily started studying math
and then um
when i was like 13 i started telling up
we have 17
going to college parties and at that
time i was also
doing meth and doing cocaine and
drinking alcohol and partying like you
i guess a normal teenager
but um
yeah i know a lot of you to my mom at
all
i went on the streets i moved into a
college
camp i moved into a college
apartment
with my best friend and now who's been
my best friend for 12 years his name is
matt
and then
his two other mates were
thomas and brandon
and thomas and brandon would molest me
in my sleep so my best friend matt told
me that i could go
live in his room and stay in his room
and so he saved me from being molested
in my sleep by the other two roommates
um when i was 14 i got in a fight at the
mall because i've been up for two weeks
and they called my mom
i told them my mom was in town
and to call my dad my dad showed up
drunk my mom showed up a little bit
after that because my dad called my mom
and then i went to mercedes hospital
which is a
rehab or a
mental health hospital in las cruces
for about two weeks
and they tested my blood and came out
positive for methamphetamine i told my
family that it was laced in my weed and
i'd never done that before which was a
lie
and then um
at age 15 i got this guy and his name
was alex or they called him tripp
and he was 27. um
this relationship was definitely one of
the worst relationships i've ever ever
had in my entire life
um
he controlled me he degraded me towards
like almost nothing he made me feel
stupid he made me feel ugly um he played
countless mind games on me
um
he really never physically abused me but
he definitely mentally
brutally and emotionally abused me
very bad um
it's actually really sad because he
would tell me that all the girls that he
would go drop sacks off to were either
you know lesbian or married or whatever
coming to find out that he's having sex
with all these girls and then
he had given me an std
and he didn't care
you know um so i don't i don't have sex
with him anymore because he give me an
sc you know but he didn't care about
that so he just texted me whenever he
wanted to
he had me so can so
under his thumb
that um
he played just my games on me and i
would fall from because i didn't know
any better
i was naive and i learned really fast
he would only have he would buy me a
phone so he could look through it when
he wanted to you could take it away when
he wanted to
um
i wasn't allowed to go anywhere do
anything abuse anybody else
ever
um but you know he was allowed to do
whatever he wanted to do
and then
um i got a cis under in my arm right
here
and it says um i uh abscessed my armor
there which is weird because i never
showed up before in my life
at this point in time
but um i guess i just got it because
i actually just don't know why i got it
but it made me so sick
that i had to sneak out from the hotel
that he got for us
i just sneaked away from him he asked me
to go buy some sodas
and i took opportunity and i left and i
went and i had to go to the hospital and
the hospital told me that if i would
have showed up if i would have waited
two more hours and i would have been
dead
he didn't care
um about me
he might it was warm in the room heater
was on
and i was so cold my skin was so pale
and my teeth were chattering and he
didn't care
so
i took the opportunity and i left i went
to the hospital like i said
and then um
he would go to jail
and he would leave me with his phone he
would tell me to call all these girls
that he was having sex with two of my on
his books
and i was seven he would get out of jail
and you know i would have to go back to
him i didn't have a choice i mean most
people didn't have a choice or i think
people in my situation have a choice but
i didn't have a choice um you know we
would get into fights and i would leave
and he would call people and tell people
that i stole his money or his drugs so
they would find me and they would take
me back to him which is not the case i
didn't see those many orders drugs that
we were just fighting so
he wanted me back so every one day i was
walking up the street on one of the main
streets and las cruces and his car pulls
over and grabs me by my hair and throws
me in the backseat of the car
and takes me back to him
um
i have been
um
i have been um less in my sleep more
times than i can count
a lot because um i don't have places to
stay when i was on the streets
so i just stayed up as long as i
possibly could and whenever i fell
asleep whenever or wherever it was
you know it usually wasn't around the
best of people so i've been molested my
sleep what happens i can remember how
many times i can count
um
i've also been raped about seven times
i've been held at knife point and raped
once um 10 days before my 18th birthday
and
you know i've had my stuff stolen from
me like everything i've ever
had was stolen from me over and over
repeatedly
like really you know i had six months
from
one point in time six months later i'd
have a completely different wardrobe
completely different everything of mine
was there because people just steal my
stuff countlessly
and um you know they would leave me
places they would take me and leave me
like up the hill stranded with no phone
no nothing
and like 102 degree weather and i think
it was leaving me up there she thought
it was funny
how long have you been in l.a i've been
only about a month now
from new mexico yeah
um so i definitely came right here how
old are you right now i'm 23 i'm about
to be 24 in october
um
so when i was 15 i started doing heroin
um
if i just said heroin like you know
rare i use on special occasions or
whatever because it was really my
drinking choice like messes always been
my drug choice i love meth like i've
always done it i've always smoked it i
actually gave myself bronchitis from
smoking so much dope
like it was crazy
um
you know
i've
been
i actually haven't i the first time i
went to joe was actually in 2019
and
that was because i was put on probation
for some charges because i had three
charges of trafficking methamphetamine
um so they put me on
probation
and i violated information so they put
me in jail and i got out of jail
went into some rehab
and in mexico they said that um they
kicked me out and said i was trying to
receive a package through the window
which was not true i actually went there
solely to get clean and to do better in
my life and to keep me out of some
charges they had against me that were um
very false accusations of me
so they kicked me out and stuff and um
i had to get to court again because i
was court ordered to be there tell them
what happened um
right after that happened i went to jail
for another two weeks got out of jail
got my ged got put into college i'm
starting my associate's degree i'm
actually college right now
after not dismissed my next semester
i'll have my associate's degree in
criminal justice
um
i don't really have any friends because
i can't seem to keep friends around me
um you know
every guy that i meet that wants to be a
friend always wants something more
and i don't get along with girls too
much um
my family has disowned me and degraded
me
and told me that was a disappointment i
had my mom in the bathroom telling me
that she wanted to kill herself because
of me
and because of how much of a failure and
a fuck-up i was
um i'm the only person in my family to
do drugs
um i'm the only person in my family who
has gone really to jail
um
[Music]
i'm in blackness to the black sheep my
family my father doesn't like that
um
has sex work been part of your life you
know what has sex work been part of your
life
did you like
you know date guys for money
um no
no
um
to be honest with you i i used to um
i used to have sex with two guys for
money and that was about it um
my sex drive was really low because all
the times that i've been raped and
molested to like i
not i can't put myself out there like
that i mean i guess it's the opposite
for some people that i've been
destroying that so they
go and be becoming shooting promiscuous
and stuff and you know they go and do
whatever but
no it's not the case for me actually um
i'm actually kind of shy and timid now
when it comes to that kind of thing
but i've definitely
definitely been through the mud and
tossed in like i've been left in ditches
and i've been like beating up to the
point where i can't remember what
happened or why it happened i just know
that i woke up in a ditch like
basically half dead covered in blood
with none of my clothes on
and
nobody around me
and um
life is hard life sucks at times it
really does
like
if you think that people are my friends
and thinking that i can trust them
um i used to trust everybody i used to
see that everybody was my friend
but um
knowing i want to write my life in
someone else's hands they took it only
for what they thought it was worth
you know i've been people were planning
to sell me to um take me to mexico and
sell me
um the only reason that they didn't is
because they couldn't find me when they
needed to find me
um so no i could definitely say that i
didn't willingly
prostitute myself
um
i didn't ever really prosecute myself
i have taken advantage of because people
have left me places
and told the people that whose house it
was
that i would have sex with them for
whatever
you know whatever which i was not aware
of any of this so they would just juggle
me and then they would rape me
because i refused to have sex with them
so they would take it however they
wanted to take it
a lot
and um
[Music]
i have like
i have a lot of problems now because of
it i have like ptsd and
um
i've always suffered from severe anxiety
and severe depression but now i have
extreme ptsd because a lot of things
that have happened to me
it makes it really hard to be in a
relationship with me
um
i'm still a very loving kind and caring
person but
i also know
when i can when i shouldn't be loving
and kind and caring to who i shouldn't
be living kind and caring too
um what emotions do you deal with
i don't know i mean it just depends
because usually
usually i really don't feel
anything
truly um
i used to come that's why i still got
myself i used to cut myself
a lot
like i used to have because of my legs
sit on my sides and stuff i guess you
can see like there's customers there
um
you know they have
because they're here
and stuff um basically here i used to
kill myself pretty much everywhere just
so it would um level out my
emotional mental pain and it would add
physical pain so it would level out my
emotional mental physical pain because i
was just going through so much that um
i couldn't talk to anybody because
nobody really wanted to hear it to be
honest with you like you know people ask
me how are you doing and like i would
always say good or okay and i really
wasn't okay or good
you know if people don't want to hear
that [ __ ] people don't want to hear how
someone's life is doing bad
they act like they care when they really
don't
what are you afraid of
um
what do you worry about
that
i'm honestly afraid that i'll never get
out of the
revolving door that my life is in right
now
um i i definitely seek happiness
and
it feels like the universe is working
against me a lot of times
and like prevent me it prevents me from
ever being truly happy
um
a lot of things that have in my past
have created ptsd makes it hard for me
to act or react in certain ways that i
guess people should
so i don't act or react in those ways
and it
messes me up
in my
anything i have ever really done
so
you know what drugs do you use most
today
uh today
i
today i am
today i'm using um
not today today oh yeah yeah just in
general lately
um
i spent weed and i drink alcohol and i'm
using fennel oh exactly
no
i definitely switched from using meth to
eat mental i guess um
just slow things down in my life my life
is extremely chaotic all the time i
repeatedly have mental breakdowns
um my best friend
my best friend and my other best friend
and my family
um i have emotional breakdowns because i
just can't handle
things in life right now
i can honestly say that there's a huge
part of me that wants to commit suicide
on a daily basis
but there's also another problem that
stops myself from doing so because i do
have a lot of life ahead of me like i'm
only 23. you know i mean
like i have a good like 20 30 years
in front of me
like i've accomplished a lot in my life
maybe not as much as other people but i
have
you know
i've been through a lot and
it's created this great amazing person
but on the back side of that it's also
created this person that has like a lot
of pain and a lot of hurt
and feeling alone and misunderstood in
the world to the world's most
worst thing that you could ever feel
um especially for the people that you
love
if you feel like they don't understand
you where they aren't there to help you
it really messes your mind you know so i
just try to
pretty much every day so your
relationship with your family is kind of
non-existent my issue with my family
right now is better really that
has been a long time
um
but
it used to be like my whole family but
then my aunt i lived when i was like
my anthem i lived when i was younger
she died about two years ago from lung
cancer cancer runs my family so right
now my only family is my mom and my
other aunt
yeah my mom is uh
almost a narcissistic hypocritical [ __ ]
sarcastic a little [ __ ]
um
she doesn't know me she doesn't want to
get to know me she says she wants to get
to know me but she doesn't
um and i have my aunt who has helped me
so much through everything
but my aunt has also given up on me
as well as my mom
i mean you know they say like the whole
like i love you and i care about you and
i'll never give up when you're happy but
i could tell my look in their face i
like they just don't see me for anything
more than what they want to believe
you know as soon as like some junkie
troublemaker whatever
but uh my mom
me seeking my mom's approval and love
and all that stuff is definitely one of
the things that messes with me the most
every day
because i really just want my mom to
love me and to understand but she i
don't think she will
and so that really hurts
like
it says like i like you counting me like
five times in the last like four days
that i've broken down crying like saying
i just wanna die and i do like enjoy the
time i really just wanna die like
life is hard and
i'm not i'm not some coward that's just
like oh my takes two suicides the easy
way out it's not like that like
i didn't honestly tell you what i told
you all the time
if i recommend suicides because i've
tried so hard
so hard to get out of this revolving
door and just be happy and be loved and
move forward and be like good luck in my
life and something always comes up and
stops it and if i feel like i'm
repeatedly gonna hit this brick wall
then i'm just gonna end my suffering
because i don't like to suffer
i really do just want to move forward
and be good in my life
but i don't know if that's ever gonna
happen
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
um
so what i have in my entire life is um
to always try to be optimistic
even though life is bad or whatever
there's always an up to a down
you know um
it always has to be equaled out
um just to be remain optimistic where
like
no matter how much
you go through in life or how shitty
life is just to always remain optimistic
the best that you possibly can
because it'll get better
all right autumn thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i wish you
the best of luck out there thank you